[Music]
Welcome, Mrs. Kalniete. You're leading Parliament's work on disinformation
and foreign interference on European democracy.
I wanted to focus today more on the disinformation
part of your work. You have already prepared two
sets of recommendations for the European
Union on how to deal with this matter and
I understand that in this process you met with
many independent journalists, legislators from
foreign countries, UN representatives...
What did you learn from this meetings?
Is there a pattern or specific challenges
in Europe when it comes to disinformation?
We have learned a lot from them but the
the general observation what I can make is
not very optimistic because
the digital reality develops so fast
that the legislative process is lagging
behind. Because technology goes faster than the
legislative process? Yes. As one of the experts said, the
situation that we are discussing today
is already yesterday. And we cannot preempt
what's going to happen... Absolutely.
Secondly, what is verydifficult
for democratic countries - and weare democratic countries -
is that we are very open
in our system. And those third countries who
have malign interests, they are manipulating
our freedoms to intervene with our freedom.
We can still learn from the past... We see in
America that disinformation has helped
to fuel violence. I still remember
the scenes of people storming the Capitol in
the United States and, a year after, people
storming the Congress in Brazil as well.
Do you see a risk of this sort of violence
also happeningin Europe?
First of all I have to say that
I'm quite optimistic about Europe in that sense.
You are speaking
about the unbelievableevents
in the U.S Congress or in Brazil. That
was the consequence of a quite long time
of spreading different harmful information, which
raises tension in society and divides
society. And part of that lies with the
president of the United States. I should say that
in Europe maybe that because of the union we are
trained more to be inclined to a compromise culture
and our politicians are more responsible. I
can't name any politician who would appeal
to a nation just to attack the Parliament. But also why
I'm so optimistic is because we really understand the
challenge of the problem and we are trying to
adopt legislation. We have a Digital Service
Act which is dealing with illegal content and
which puts also the responsibility on platforms
to assess the risks and also to control the
content which is distributed in the social
networks. Secondly, we strengthened the
first attempt to propose for the platforms a
sort of agreement of behavior, which is called
the Democracy Action Plan. The first attempt
was called the Code of Conduct, but it's not flawless
because it's voluntarily. The biggest platforms all
agreed and they are trying to implementit.
But there are a multitude of small
servers and platforms that are not part of that
agreement. And some of them are quite aggressive.
So we have to find a way to also impose this behavior on
them. In the two reports that
you prepare for Parliament you mention that
social network platforms are not doing their part,
are not doing enough. And I want to highlight
that your two reports, one was last year and the
other one has just been adopted this week. Does it mean
that in 12 months nothing has
improved? That is the question about
strengthening the toolbox, which we are already
doing. And the most important thing is to understand how the algorithms
work. They have to be more transparent.
There has to be accessibility for
researchers and also for fact checkers, social
networks. I think the most important tool, which
Parliament already adopted, is the Digital Service
Act, because it's dealing with illegal content
and imposing on social platforms certainobligations
that they have to follow. And one of your
recommendations is that actions to counter disinformation should go hand in hand with actions
to promote free speech and other fundamental rights.
This might seem contradictory. Could you explain to
us how fighting against disinformation
helps promoting free speech and vice versa?
Sounds quite contradictory. But this is something
that I understand profoundly because of all of my experience.
Why do we need to counter disinformation? Because
disinformation appeals psychologically to
human beings by serving what they want
to hear, and then they base their decisions and
understanding of reality on this bubble in which
they are included because of likes they are making.
That is the job done by algorithms. Why do we need
to promote truly free speech and information?
Because that information is based on facts and by
providing the truthful picture of any ofthese
problems we are providing freedom of speech,
freedom of information. What you mention about
algorithms make me think of one thing: there
are some psychological studies that say that
people tend to believe what they want to believe,
actually. And I guess that people and institutions
interested in sowing disinformation
take profit from that. How
can we tackle this problem? This problem is as old,
as ancient as human nature. It's very
very human nature. And the difference between disinformation a few centuries ago and disinformation
currently is exactly the quantity of disinformation, the instruments with which it could
be dispersed around the world and the speed with
which it's distributed. But as I mentioned, exactly
because there is micro targeted disinformation.
For instance, the 2016 campaign of President Trump
was precisely built on that. And that is the year
when democratic countries realised the
danger of that intervention
and interference in democratic processes.
But the only way we can help to build
resilience, I think, is through education.
And here again we are facing a problem. We can
recommend and suggest, but the system of education
is entirely the responsibility of member states.
And are they doing enough on media literacy? There
are quite many different programmes and projects
to help to deal with media literacy, but I still
think that we need more of a systematic approach and
to allocate more financial resources for that.
Because media literacy still has loopholes as to
very young people and also to the senior citizens
who are out of these programmes and tools.
They are not so skillful to deal with them.
My conviction, if we speak generally about
this enormous, complex...  is that it is a mistake
to deal with the digital revolution in
the compartments. I think the basic problem is that
we don't have a complex approach for that. And if I'm
looking at the future, I think that we are facing a
complete change of reality with artificial
intelligence, which will require changing
practically everything. There is also the
the question of definition... Who decides what
is disinformation, what is true and what is a lie?
You have asked on your reports for the EU to step
up action to come up with an international common
definition of disinformation, like some countries
have for hate crimes or for racism. Why is it
important to have a common definition of
disinformation? You have to have a common language. You
have to know what that word contains. But this isan
extremely difficult task, to find the
common definition for disinformation. I went
to the UN with the delegation of our committee and
we discussed it in different departments and also
with different representatives from
different member statesof the
United Nations. It just showed what
the difficulties are. For countries in theEuropean Union
it's quite easy. Because we
have the same values... We have the same set of values,
but these values are notthe
values of the entire community
of the United Nations. There are
also countries in which democracy is...
let's call it controlled democracy, which is a sort
of manipulation of the elections. Then there are
autocracies and there are also dictatorships.
For them disinformation is an ideological tool to
ensure control over the country. and that's
why the European Union has to take the lead in that and at
least agree on the term of disinformation
among ourselves. For several other difficult
problems we have been the the settlers of language,
the settlers of terminology, the settlers of trend.
And then gradually it is adopted by other
institutions. In your report you also  introduce the
concept of "high-risk third country". What is this
about and which countries are you talking about?
Currently all our relationships with the world outside from
European Union are based on the country agnostic
approach, which means that we treat all
countries equally. But at the same time
we know that all those countries
are not equalif we use
different objective criteria. I'm proposing
that we treathigh-risk third countries
according to objective criteria. It could
be - and I will read them -
the activity of foreigninterference
which is fact-checked and based on evidence,
the systematicstealing of
intellectual property fromthe Union
and its member states. One criteria that for me
is important is the consistent violation of human
rights in the country. For instance, in the case of
Russia, the blatant revision of the international order
by acts of aggression. You mentioned
Russia, China. Are there other countries that we
can mention already? There are. We can speak
about Iran...  Practically, there are a multitude
of countries, but none of them can achieve
such a volume and diversity of interference
as Russia and China. So those are
the main ones? Yes. Coming back to the European
elections, we are one year away from the European
elections. In your report you also mention that
Russia is investing massively in financing
political parties in democratic countries.
How can this affect the the information scenario in
Europe? You are touching one of the issues
which are absolutely vital for the existence of
our democracy, because democracy is an open system.
As soon as there is a hostile third
country coming in with its own interests,
financing so-called governmental, non-governmental
organisations or proxy foundations which are
used to strengthen their interests, which are
used to divide our societies, then we have to
protect ourselves. I think that one of the most
important parts of elections is to strengthen the
electoral instruments, which is the voting system,
the counting of votes, etc. Secondly, it's a
media freedom pact that provides independence
for media, which is protected against manipulative
media, which supports investigative journalism.
Because investigative journalists
are those who can follow that dirty money, how
it is, in a very covert way, seeping into the
Union and complicating the normal democratic
process. Of course, as we before we were
speaking about media literacy, about fact checking,
about resilience against the manipulation and fake
news, all of that is also important. You also alerted that
Russia and perhaps other countries are likely to
step up their misleading narratives against
Europe ahead of the elections to try
and influenciate the European elections from
next year. And there are some media reports that
Russia has tripled the budget for
propaganda about the Ukrainian war and that part
of this money and this propaganda are also to be
spread in other countries, not only internally in
Russia. How can Europe oppose this
communication warfare? The first steps were very
speedy. We closed Sputnik and Russia Today. These
were broadcasting in many countries and in many
languages. That was a very strong
signal to Russia that we are not going to accept
that sort of disinformation instruments in
the European Union. The problem is that Russia
Today, Sputnik and other media immediately
switched to areas where we have no power
to forbid: to social media networks. So people
could still go around and watch them... Yes. Telegram, Tick Tock
and Facebook... Whatever! That is one of the the
problems. We also have to replace it with proactive
content which is attractive and interesting
for those who are the consumers, who have beenthe
consumers of Russia Today and Sputnik. And this
is something that we are currently trying to do.
To conclude this interview... We're having
this conversation here in the House of European
History, which is a museum managed by the European
Parliament here in Brussels. What is history's
role in disinformation? Does it help to counter
disinformation or does it help promote it?
Howdo you see it? I would say that for years and years
we were quite indifferent to the historical
truth and to historical justice, and it created
a very beneficial platform for the Kremlin, for Putin
to manipulate historical facts, to introduce
their own interpretations of them. And look where
we are now. Because the Kremlin justifies their
aggressive, non-provoked attack on Ukraine
with a complete historical manipulation
of facts, stating that Ukraine never has beenan
independent country, that it is not a nation.
It shows how important it is that we are
scrupulous when we are dealing with history
and historical facts. For instance, deportations.
I was born in Siberia from deported parents and in
this Museum I presented as a gift a letter of
my grandfather from the Gulag. I would say, until our countries entered the European Union,
Communism and the crimes of Communism were not
really on the agenda of Western countries.
But, for instance, next month in the European
Parliament we will have for the first time
the official commemoration ceremony
for deportations of 1941. Now,
30 years after the Iron Curtain fell, it's the first
time that a ceremony will take place. Why am I
speaking about it? Because from the occupied
territories of Ukraine, more than 20
000 children were deported. The Russian Duma adopted a law
which allows the urgent adoption of Ukrainian children.
They are deprived of their national identity,
converted into someone they arenot.
It just shows that history repeats itself
if we do not strictly stand for truth. We accept
silence because this is more comfortable, but
then it's very easy to repeat it again.
[Music]